ça fait un petit moment qu'on n'a pas
fait de vidéo sur les transitions moi je
dis ça serait sympa d'en faire une
nouvelle genre genre ça
[Musique]
saoudi on y va bon ok mais juste après
l'intro comme d'habitude c'est toujours
l'intro qui voit la tête après l'intro
[Musique]
il salue les gens derrière l'écran c'est
françois pour la chaîne explique mme
encore je suis ravie comme toujours de
vous retrouver sur cette chaîne où on
parle de vidéos de montage de prise de
vue tout ça tout ça
donc si ça vous plait bien évidemment
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner il y aura
sûrement des choses qui vont vous plaire
sur cette chaîne sur obligé obligé alors
aujourd'hui une fois n'est pas coutume
on va faire une vidéo relativement
courte puisque ce tuto il est rapide
cette technique elle est simple cette
transition on la voit beaucoup c'est
d'un étang dans plein de vidéos
donc je voulais vous montrer comment on
l'a fait mais avant ça quand même je
voudrais vous recommandez vous mettre en
garde contre l'abus de transition
attention de trop de transition tu as
pas la transition mais tu le film la
transition elle doit avoir un sens elle
doit avoir un objectif là ici je vous
montre comment on l'a fait à vous de
voir quand ça sera judicieux de
l'utiliser 1
mais on en n'est pas partout tout le
temps sinon sinon c'est ça sert à rien
on a plus d'histoire on n'a plus rien à
voir là sauf si ça sert un scénario est
bien entendu ça se passe sur final cut
un petit logo sur la miniature voilà
c'est le truc de panique
voilà c'est parti alors première chose
ici j'ai mis mes deux plans que je veux
enchaîner d'accord donc ce qu'on va
faire c'est qu'ici on va couper
commandes b le morceau ici qui va venir
s'enchaîner avec celui là ce que je vais
faire c'est que je vais faire glisser ce
plan au dessus du premier alors là rien
ne change c'est ce plan là qui est lu
celui s'il en dessous on ne le voit pas
et ensuite ça passe sur ce plan ici pour
faire ma transition l'humain fait je
vais aller chercher un effet natif de
final cut qui s'appelle incruste ateurs
de luminance le nom tu vois bien que de
trucs que tu vas pas aller voir
naturellement quoi alors ici un cru ce
d'atr en luminance il est là je vais
venir le glissé sur mon plan ici là j'ai
une espèce de fondue qui est ma foi pas
vilain mais c'est pas ça que je veux du
tout moi je veux cet effet de
dissolution en fonction de la lumière
donc je vais me placer au tout début de
ce plan
allez ici dans les réglages et venir
placer une ti frame au début je ramène
tout ici donc si je regarde bien en fait
là j'ai quasiment supprimé mon effet je
vais maintenant venir me placer à la fin
de mon plan et venir attraper ce curseur
là ici pour le ramener tout à gauche et
idem pour celui du dessous et boum j'ai
ma transition
pas plus compliqué alors on peut rentrer
bien entendu dans les réglages un petit
peu plus fin un ici on peut faire des
choses peut-être un petit peu plus
progressive mais bon c'est pas forcément
intéressant dans d'un outil cash on va
pouvoir travailler un peu plus
l'adoucissement des bords d'avoir
quelque chose d'un petit peu plus un
petit peu plus flou si on veut et
rejoindre c'est un petit peu pareil ça
va rogner un petit peu sur la partie qui
apparaît encore mais voilà c'est du
fignolage le gros de la transition c'est
juste soit facile rapide cool pour part
de notre côté et voilà c'était pas plus
compliqué vous avez une nouvelle
transition dans votre trousse à
transition ça existe ça une trousse
transition je sais pas c'est à vous
maintenant de l'utiliser comme il faudra
dans vos transition j'en profite
également pour vous encourager à venir
me suivre sur instagram
il ya plein de choses qui se passent en
story je vous raconte plein de trucs là
en ce moment je n'entends pas mal de
matériel j'ai reçu plein de trucs donc
venez faire un petit tour sur l'oeil
dans la boîte sur instagram ya les liens
dans la description la formation pour
débuter sur le final cut elle est
toujours sur une amy elle est toujours
super bien noté est toujours super cool
donc vous pouvez y aller faire un tour
et puis si cette vidéo elle vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à mettre le traditionnel
coup de blaster sur le pouce en l'air
qui se situe en dessous de cette vidéo
oui je vous ai demandé dans la vidéo
d'avant s'il fallait changer vous avez
tous dit non car le blaster et tout donc
on garde le blaster d'accord d'accord
d'accord on garde le blaster c'est la
marque de fabrique
on garde le blaster puis si ce n'est pas
déjà fait vous pouvez vous abonner
surtout à activer la clause prince
moment youtube mais pas trop de
notification à ceux qui ont pas mis la
cloche donc si vous voulez être notifiée
quand il ya une nouvelle vidéo
il faut mettre la cloche puis voilà et
puis c'est tout c'était une vidéo rapide
pour une fois j'ai fait qu voilà c'est
j'ai réussi champions et donc je vous
dis comme toujours rester curieux hyper
curieux toujours plus curieux et à très
bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo
et puis pour ceux qui restent toujours à
la fin eh bien il faut rester jusqu'à la
fin parce que je vous raconte des trucs
sympas des fois j'ai reçu ça là cet
objectif ça oui c'est un objectif c'est
pas une flûte c'est pas on va faire des
trucs cool avec ça
[Musique]